This first option might look tempting and in fact the null hypotheses is
correct. But one problem with ANOVA is that we can only tell if at least one
pair is significantly different. That's what makes our statistic big. We have
one statistic that's either big or small. If we get a small statistic, we know
that the within subject variability is large relative to the between subject
variability. And none of the means are significantly different from each other.
In that case, we would accept the null hypothesis. But if we get a large
statistic, the opposite is true. The between subject variability is large.
Relative to the within subject variability. In other words we might have some
samples, and the means are different from each other, relative to each
variability. But then we know that at least one pair of means is significantly
different. So we accept the alternative hypothesis. But we don't know which
means are causing this large between subject variability. This means that when
we're doing ANOVA, if we get a large test statistic and reject the null.
There's an extra step that involves seeing which means are different from each
other. These follow-up tests are generally called multiple comparison tests.
And you'll learn about these in the next lesson.